I got emails over the weekend David you
wouldn't dare cover the investigation
into congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez it doesn't fit your
narrative to talk about the fact that
she's under ethics investigation come on
guys come on you all know I do not care
about political party or these elected
officials as people and what I mean by
that is it's it's not like I'm saying I
don't I don't care if they get hit by a
car no that's not what I mean is The
Cult of Personality that forms around so
many elected officials I just don't care
about it these are just people they all
they're all they do good they do bad
they have good ideas they have ideas I
don't care for aoc's just another person
that's all and so I would have no reason
to hide from you that AOC is the subject
of a house ethics investigation that's
absolutely the case that that is going
on and it has been under a democratic
house
that's happening the guardian reports
AOC is subject of house ethics
investigation
spokesperson is confident undisclosed
matter quote will be dismissed
the Democratic acting chair Susan Wilde
and acting ranking member Michael guest
released a statement on Wednesday they
say the matter regarding AOC was
transmitted to the committee by the
office of congressional ethics on 23
June the subject was not revealed the
committee said the mere fact of a
referral or an extension and the
mandatory disclosure of such an
extension and the name and subject of
the subject of the matter does not
itself indicate a violation has occurred
what they're saying is
you're innocent until proven guilty
there is an investigation but that
doesn't mean that any violation has
taken place
the house Ethics Committee said it would
announce its course of action after the
new Congress convenes in January
that's what's going on
uh now in September of 2021 the American
accountability Foundation filed an
Ethics complaint against her for quote
accepting an impermissible gift to
attend the Met Gala the event was a 35
000 a ticket event that's where she wore
the tax the rich dress a spokesperson
said she was invited as a guest of the
met and didn't get to keep the dress the
question is whether that may have
violated the ethics rules because even
though she was a guest someone paid for
the ticket and the thirty five thousand
dollar ticket is worth more than the
maximum donation so that there may be
something there now
when some something like this happens
what should the left do for the most
part the left does what it should do if
you think back to Anthony Weiner you
know the the Wright loves to say oh the
left is they have these double standards
they want to go after everyone on the
right but then they want to protect
Hunter Biden or they were defending
Anthony Weiner or they think that an
investigation into AOC is by definition
wrong because she's the darling of the
left
I don't see anyone doing that stuff
think back to the Anthony Weiner
circumstances my view on Anthony Weiner
was skilled politician great speaker
doesn't deserve any particular
protection for the things he is accused
of and he did things wrong and he has to
suffer the consequences with Al Frank
and remember the the bad joke and the
picture with Al Franken that
subsequently left to him led to him
resigning from the Senate
Democrats if they could be criticized
for anything on that were too quick to
demand a resignation too quick when in
the end it seemed like it was more of a
bad joke and misunderstanding than
anything approximating the things that
the right has done and has been accused
of uh uh Hunter Biden listen I don't
know anyone saying Hunter Biden must be
protected there is obviously a political
bias going on when it comes to the
targeting of Hunter Biden there is an
attempt to conflate Hunter Biden with
Joe Biden when Hunter has nothing to do
with the Biden Administration there is
no proof that the big guy that is
referenced in the infamous emails is Joe
by there's just it's obviously grasping
at straws because they have nothing but
I and everybody I'm seeing on the left
says Hunter Biden did something wrong
then investigate him and indict him if
it's a crime and convict him if the
evidence is there who cares nobody is
defending him and similarly if AOC did
something wrong there should be an
investigation and if it turns out that
indeed she did do something wrong there
should be whatever punishment is
appropriate we just can't have it be
partisan witch hunts that's the concern
and that's why with Hunter Biden when he
clearly has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration the desire to turn the
next Congress into the Congress that
will impeach Biden for things we don't
even really know and investigate Hunter
Biden for the full two years that's when
it gets disgusting and concerning so
that's where we are
let's figure out what AOC did if
anything if she should be fined then
let's find her that's it but let's make
sure that we're doing it equally and
that we're not turning this into a
partisan Witch Hunt we're going to take
a quick break and be right back after
this